smile for even an elimination you have
become children of Brady we have a
25-point lead feel like people are never
gonna let me get over this one more and
I'll have just as many as the Steelers
Thomas it's coming you all in the AFC
need to stop him if he wins again it
will be boring on a skill this league
has never seen prepare the offense
engage all defenses and get this man a
coach who can maximize a serviceable
Talent hey I'm a computer man
something's wrong st. Louis is deserted
all that's left is baseball in to Six
Flags I need you to pay me it's the only
way to stop braiding the dog is he okay
twenties in the AFC I will restore order
to the universe don't want to take
helico it's working I see so many
articles about how this could be the end
of the Patriots dynasty budget Brady
stop micromanage adho ever calm down
give him back the balls but geez
overtime overtime rules Tom gets the
punch first if he misses Patrick gets
the punch work the end of the game now
the Rams are our last chance me and the
Rams had a bit of a falling out yeah
well I should win no I should win okay
Todd now might be a good time to unleash
the girl eh oh yeah somewheres going on
with me right now
Watts Ave wait no name position players
totally expandable attack old thing
still works
Hallet better I don't even know who you
are Garrett the system quarterback just
like you not true
you shouldn't have gone for my head no
roughing the passer oh good a new sit
back oh hell yeah I get to disappear
again
mr. bruised hello I blame the refs and I
refuse to accept this reality okay so
that's one of the 14 million ways this
could go down let's practice it again
Pano's didn't go far enough hello you
feeling dangerous subscribe to this
channel to watch more episodes
woo I'm so high for this haters gonna
hate